Ihmettelevä, kansalainen, tässä hei parallaan, minä ihmettelen todella tuota, noita puhelioperaattoreita, kun ne myy noita puhelinliittymiä, ja niihin kaikkiin kuuluu sitten, tietenki se netti.
Eihän kaikilla oo älypuhelinta, jossa on netti, eli ne nettuaa niillä, ne pitää hirviää hintaa sillä puhelinliittymällä. Perivät netihinnan, vaikka ihminen ei pysty ees nettiä käyttää, eikö tuohonkin pitäis jo puuttua? Olokaapa ihmiset tarkkoina.
Puolituntisen aikana on luvassa puhetta esimerkiksi liikenteestä, sotesta ja ylästä.
Tällä kertaa kansan ajatukset on haravoinut kasaan, Koiviston Lauri.
Erassoittaja ehdottaa koulaisten polkupyöriin turvaviirejä.
Toisen kansalaisen mielestä sairaalan kanttiinissa on liian korkeat hinnat, niin ja televisiossa vain villautellaan.
Ja nyt on Heikin vuoro.
No, Heikki, historia tässä. Kattelee juuri televisiota, missä yhtäkkiä on huomattu, että Etelä, Amerikassa on ollut suuria sivilisaatioita, paljon ihmisiä, paljon rakennuksia.
Nyt huomataan se. On se aika käsittämätöntä, että tämmöset asiat huomataan nyt, kun kirjailija Erich Dennicken muun muassa on kirjoittanut useampia kirjoja vastaavasta alueesta.
Sitä ennen jo, nämä ristiretken, Portugalin, Espanian purjeetjat, jotka löysivät tätä Etelä-Amerikkaa, niin kuvasivat niistä ihmelisyyksistä, ja siellähän puhuttiin kaiken maailman ufoista ja muista, jotka olis kehittänyt tätä ihmiskuntaa silläkin alueella.
Ja nyt, tiedemiehet ovat huomanneet, että alleluja, siellä on, Etelä-Amerikassa on, vanha, suuri kulttuuri, ehkä miljoonia asukkaita.
Tää on vanhaa vitsiä, kerran lämmitetty. No, ei siinä mitään se ole hyvä, että nuorempia ihmisiä rivistetään tästä samasta asiasta, mistä jo varmasti viiskuis sukupolvea on ollut tietoisia.
Siinä oltiin liikkeellä vähän kauempanakin. Nyt meitä sivistetään puheluilla, joissa liikutaan pikkuisen lähempänä.
Niiteni, ette lahjottamasisivat, totano, tämmöset, näite heille. Kiva, kiitos, moi.
Täällä soittaa vihanen autoilija. Se on kyllä nii väärin, että jos ajoneuvovero joutuu maksaa useimmassa osassa, niin se niinku maksaa enemmän se loppusumma, kun se, et se maksais kerralla pois.
Tää on mumme, siis sehän oikeasti selvä väärys, mikä pitäis korjata, että mitä ihmeen rahastamista tää tämmönen o.
Ilkasaukkaaurasta.Tänään tässä viides yhdeksättä lauantaina radiosta tuli tällainen maistiaisosa kansan radios, jossa puhuttiin siitä, että vanhat naiset ja farmariautot ovat riski parkkipaikoilla, mutta kuitenkin tämä henkilö sanoi, että syy on se, että päätteivät.
Mutta minä olen sitä mieltä, että jos pää kääntyy, itsekin kun olen liikenteessä, ja huomaan, että parkkipaikalta joku lähtee liikkeelle, pää kääntyy, ovi aukeaa, ja seurataan sitä kautta ikään kuin.
Ja, että mihin mennää?
Jos niin tekee, niin silloin jää kokonaan oikeanpuoleinen peilikäyttää.
Peilit on autoihin laitettu, sitä varten, että niiden avulla peruutetaan, ei pään kääntymisellä riittää, kun silmät liittää.
Kiitos Ilkalle, nyt on vuorossa asia, josta tuli eniten kommentteja viime viikon ohjelmasta. Teeman aloittaa tämä sähköposti.
Rouva kyseli sunnuntain kuudes syyskuuta lähetyksessä neuvoja siihen, mitä tehdä, kun rajapyykki on kadonnut.
Ohje, kannattaa ottaa yhteyttä oman alueen maanmittausyksikköön. Sieltä saa varmasti oikeat ohjeet.
Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka meillä oli lähettänyt Sini.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
No päivää päivää.
Päivää päivää.
Minä kuulun tähän mummosarja, joka on perämeet tässä, joka haluu valittaa vähäsen kans.
Asia on vanha, mutta ärsyttävä. Asun täällä, tämmösellä vanhalla pikku maatilalla.
Siinä oli mettätöitä, tehtiin tossa naapurissa kanssa.
No, nehän on ne Ilmakuva-jutut, mihin tulee se rasti sinne ylös, kun ne kuvaa tontirajoja ja sellaisia.
Niin, yks meidän rasti oli sitten tietysti, siinä kun meidän puujuuressa oli sitten, meidän, tää rajamerkki.
Niin, ei siinä mitään auttanu.
Tää menin kattomaan, ne oli vienyt siitä se rajakuus.
Kyllä mä olin sitten kiukkune ja vihane, ja soitiin sitten vaan tälle maanomistelemästä, mikäs peli tää on.
Ei sehän ei vikaa, se on mettähallituksen.
No, sitä, aha, toisen rajamerkimeltä vei sitten sähtävaitos.
Ja sitten, kun kyselin sitä tuolta maanmittausaitokselta, niin, no se lähtee siinä tonnista rahana, jos haluat määrittää sen uuden rajapyykki siihen.
Eipähän sitä oikein oo sitten varaa, näitä rajapyykkiä uusia.
Kylä se ei mieleksii, jos joku on semmose hävittely, niin kyllä se kannattais sitten se hukkajan siihen takaisin laittaakin.
Tässä, kun tää rouva puhu siitä tossa äsken, tossa lähetyksestä.
Mutta tämmösiä mettä asioita, tätä, mettän pereitä, mutta muuten, tänään paistaa aurinkoja, kaikki näyttää hyvältä.
Näisyksyksyks.
Se on hyvä kuulla. Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta, ja hyvää syyspäiväjatkoa.
Sitä samaa telle.
Juu, hei vaan.
No hei, tääl on Anna.
Hei, hei.
Kuullaan niistä rajapyyköistä.
Nieillä on ihan sama ollut, että mä oon ollut siellä melkein 40 vuotta siellä paikassa.
Se on semmoinen pianikesäpaikka.
Ei, sit siinä oli kivi, ja siellä oli punosta, siinä kivessä.
Ja sitten se kivihävis, ja sitten siihen tuli hiljakkoin semmoinen puutappi, missä oli numero ja punainen ylhäältä, mutta siinä siis numero oli joku. Se vietiin kanssa.
Mutta tommonen juttu mä ajattelin, että vois ilmoittaa sinne.
Siella oli semmoinen, mä en näe, kun ne mittas sitä, ja ne mittas oikein hyvin.
Se laittoi uudestaan sen, ku siinä ei ollut enää sitä kiveä.
Ku siinä oli numero, ni se voisi sillä lailla, että jos muistais sen numeron, ja heti ku se on otettu pois, ni soittaa kaupungille, mistä ne laittoi.
Siella oli kaupungilla ne mittamiäjat, ni sanoi, että tämä numero, se ja se, on hävitetty, että tämä kaupungin on tietäis, että ne hävittää, jos se kerran rikosoi.
Minä en ollut sieltä tehnyt mitään ilmoituksia, mutta kyllä se harmittaa, ku niil on jo, sinne on mitään ideaa viedä sitä tappia pois.
Selvä, kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta, ja oikea hyvää sunnotajatkoa.
Kiitoksia itsellesi, hyvää sunnotajata, hei!
Ritko, moisio, terveys.
Terve, terve.
Ko siellä yks Rouva kysyy, että rajaa asioistani, jota yle maamittauslaitokselta saa tilattua maamittarin paikalle, joko näyttää ne tarkat rajaa arvotettu.
Nieli, asia on helposti hoidettavissa.
No, helposti, ja helposti, se on tietysti, ihmisistä kiinni.
Toinen asia, mitä haluaisin, jos saa vielä heittää, niin.
Tää roskaaminen, et ku ihmiset ei tiedä, että voisinko viedä, totani, sorttiasemalle, semmoinen, minne saa vielä metallia, elektroniikkaa, hynä muuta, tämmöstä vapaata, että niitä heittää luontoa, niin se on niinku.
Tämmönen, mitä pitäis, eh, ehkä tuolla yleisessä tiedotteessa niinku pistää ihmisten tietoa enemmän.
Ei, voitanko hyvää päivänjatkoa.
Kiitoksia sitä samaa. Hei, hei.
Onto.
Mitä muita kommentteja on tullut viime jaksoen puheenvuoroihin?
No, se selviää aivan juuri.
Ennen puheluita, yksi WhatsApp viesti.
Moro kansanradio, hiiren loukuista.
Muovinen perästä aukeavattava loukku, on tehokkain.
Syöttinä toimii parhaiten halvin, pyöreä kullanruskea keksi.
Loukku täytyi kiinnittää metallikettjulla, jossa nipistin, muuten nakitettu, voi viedä sen mennessään.
Myrkkypusseissa kokemuksena, jyrsiä oli levittänyt pussin sisällön lattialle ja syönyt kaura hiutaleet ja jättäneet vaaleanpunaiset hiutaleet syömättä.
Pastamyrkky on tapava hermomyrkky, toimii, raatometrin päässä.
Palamyrkkyä olen kolmatta vuotta, antanut olla paikallaan, ei kelpaa kenellekään.
Tällä tavoin luki WhatsApp viestissä, jonka meillä oli lähettää nymerkki Josa Hämeestä.
Meille Kansaradion voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä äskeisenlaisia tekstimuotoisia, että myös ääniviestejä.
Kansaradion WhatsApp-numero on: 0, 4, 4, 5, 5, 1, 5, 4, 6, 4.
Pirre uudeltamalta? Hei, mies suunnultana ehdotti hyvään ehdotuksen.
Kansan edustajille alkupalkka, ja siihen lisät, kun saa jotain aikaiseksi.
Kannatan. Palkka vai läsnäolosta, normaalitöistä saa, potkut, lorvimisesta.
Peroimaksajien velkataakkaa lisää, ilmait, lentomatkat, juna ja bussi sekä taksimatkat, matkakorvauksia ulkomailta ja lomamakkoilta, tapahtumalippuja ynnä muuta.
Onko kansan edustajille palkalista lomaa neljästä viiteen kuukautta vuodessa? Hyvää syksyä kaikille.
Hei, minä otan kantaa myrmäkeläisen katin kokemukseen. Olen ollut kaksi vuotta kepillä ja rollattorilla kulkeva mummo.
Lussissa ja junassa olen saanut hyvin invapaikan, ja jos on tarve? Ystävällisesti olen pyytänyt, pääsisinkö siihen istumaan? Minä kiitän syvästi nuoria ja iäkkäitä miehiä avusta ja oven aukaisusta.
Nuorin taitaa olla kahdentoista vuoden huijakoilla. Täytyy meidän naisten häpeäksi sanoa, että ei tällaista apua ole. Meiltä toisillemme herunut.
Moikka, Marietta.
Täällä 90-vuotias Anja Moorisotkomusta. Olipa hyvä erotus tämä kansanradion hyvien asioiden ohjelma.
Niä kaikilla on varmuna hyviäkin asioita kerrottavana. Minulla ainakin on nii paljon, että jo niista saisi ainakin hyvien kansanradion ohjelma ajan täyteen.
Nutta se on kyllä tosi asias, että sen voin kertoa vuosien kokemuksesta, että ne huulot asiat kyllä pääsee paremmin julkisuuteen.
Sea on hyvä asia, sillä sitirannes pääsee korjaamaan tilanteet paremmin julkisuuteen.
Nyt Tiemö vie maailmanpolitiikan näyttämöille.
Mielipiteitä tietysti saa näyttää ja niille olla jotain mielenosoituksia ja on eri mieltä siitä ja siitä, mitä meidän päättäjät tekee.
Mutta se on nazismia ja rasismia, että on mielenototus juutalaisia vastaan.
Pitäis pikkuisen aatella, että rasistiset mielenototuset on kielletty, se ei käy.
Ja juutalaiset on edyt maailmassa niin paljon hyvää, antakaa heitä hoittaa oma maassa, jonka he on saanut.
He hoittaa omaa maatansa ja puolestaa sitä. Se on ehkä mennyt vähän yli, mutta kyllä se siitä menee.
En mene sen enempää puhumaan tästä asiasta, mutta rasistiset mielentonsoitukset täytyy kieltää.
Hyvää päivää, hyvä kansanarion kuuntelijat ja toimitu, Taunoluuri Alavurel.
Pitää nostaa lattiaa korkialle, näitten islantilaatille, kuinka viksoa porukkaa ne oli.
Siihen nähden, mitä suomalaiset silloin 1994 vuonna.
Islantilaatet äänestivät vapauden puolet, kutkaisinko nämä suomalaiset.
Poistuu mieleen, kuinka kiirus oli viedä Rysseliin anomustatta päästään avaamaiseksi sinne.
Alivaltiosihteeri joutuu juoksemaan auton vierellä, ku auto oli jo liikkeellä.
Näin kova hätä oli päästä EU-jäseneksi.
Mutta, täytyy nyt tanua tässä, jotta ei näitä suomalaisia nu aina voi mollata.
Täytyy tätä huolustusministeriä huolustaa.
Hän teki oikean päätöksen, kun hän teki sopimuksen, jatkosopimuksen Israelin kanssa,
näistä asehankin nousta.
Kyllä se sillä lailla on, että Suomen pitää hankkia, varastaa aseistutta, mitä on saatavista.
No, eipä tämän kummentaa.
No, te soittaa, mutta kyllä, minä nyt tätä Suomen politiikko ei mettele,
kun ne hyväksyy Israelin lasten tappamisen, mutta ei Venäjänä.
Aseissopimus, ette, voi vee, ei muuta.
Ei muuta ulkomaan politiikasta, sillä nyt siirrymme vahvemmin kotimaitiseen päätöksentekoon.
Taino, nyt tässä kansardyn verkkosivoen lomakkeella lähetystätekstissä ollaan jossain näiden kahden asian välissä.
Karjoismaiden tulisi erota Euroopan unionista ja perustaa yhteinen unioni.
Suomi, Ruotsi, Norja, Tanska ja Islanti muodostaisivat noin 28 miljoonaan asukkaan erittäin vauraan, teknologisesti kehittyneen ja luonnonvaroltaan poikkeuksellisen vahvan kokonaisuuden.
Sillä olisi öljyä ja kaasua, vesivoimaa, metsää, mineraaleja, ydinvoimaa, erittäin vahva meriklusteri, puolustusteollisuutta, telekommunikaatiota ja merkittävä arktinen asema.
Maat ovat institutionaalisesti, taloudellisesti ja yhteiskunnallisesti lähempänä toisiaan, kuin esimerkiksi Suomi ja Välimeren maat.
Yhteinen maatalous, energia, kalastus ja teologispolitiikka voi taisin räätälöidä pohjoisiin olosuhteisiin.
Energia ja raakainen omavaraisuus olisi erittäin vahva.
Etelän maita ei paljon kiinnosta muu, kuin oman edun ajaminen. Se on nähty.
"Dead Cleider in", Nymerkki, oli lähettänyt tämän tekstin kansaradion verkkosivojen lomakkeella.
"Suomi oi ei jämähtänyt oho. Tulee taas Ilmotyön leikkausia, mitä ei reagoida, tulee vaan maahan sitten, sit tutkitaa, jos se ois ollut juu räähde.
Ei muuta, ku tulee heti tieto tutkistaa tai joku uhkaa, ni horretit sinne ja ammuta ales kaikki.
Onko se nii vaikeeta? Otetaan vaan riske, että ei tänne kuka hyökkää. Antakaa nyt laulaa niiden horretteen kanssa, vielä kun ne on vielä. Kiitos."
"Tuleekohan tässä ihan vainoharhaiseksi, kun kuuntelee, ihan Suomen uutisia, ja sanotaan, että joku tieto jää menimättä jollekin ihan korkealla tasolla.
Henkilökohtaisen virheen takia, ollaanko sitä katsottu tarpeeksi, kaiken maailman murhamysteerejä ja poliittisia koukeroita elokuvissa ja sarjoissa.
Voitaisiko niistä oppia? Että missä on se back-upi?", elikkä se varmistus.
"Kaaksankymppinen eläkeläne tässä, moikka!"
"Petteri Orpo, miksi valehtelet Suomen kansalle?"
"Petteri Orpo, miksi olet niin ylimielinen? Miksi hymyet kuin Euroopakuningas? Moi!"
"Hyvät kansaradiomistävät, täällä soittaa täält Turun läheltä, Mettä laidasta, mummeli", niin kuin lapsi lapsi sanoo.
"Olin kuunnellut radiotiototeki telkkariani puhua tällaista hallituspohjasta, uudesta hallituspohjasta, mutta minun mielipiteeni on oikein ihan selvä, että nykyinen hallituspohja on mitä parhain.
"Turvallinen ja tasapuolinen, ja yrittää auttaa kaikkia, nämä, tämän hallituspohjan, nämä, nämä kansaedustijat ja ministerit ynnä muut, ketkä siellä päättää, meidän asioitamme.
Et kannata nykyistä hallituspohjaa, se on ihan hyvä ja aikansaava, ja varmaan parantaa vielä kaikkia muitakin, ja kaikille hyvät edut ja hyvät voinnit vaan kaikille, heippa hei!""
"Täällä on yks mummo pirkammailta. Minkälaista kieltä on Suomen ministerillä mahdollisuus käyttää, mitä ne kehtaa sanoa televisiossa uutilisessa, onko enää mitä rotia, kun kuuntelee näiden ministeriitten puheenvuoroja, hippa!""
"Erilaisia sote-asioita tarjoillaan nyt, siispä suu auki, ja sanokaa aaa!""
"Yngve ruotsi pyhtältä päivää, toi Porvon sairaalan touhu ihmetyttää, synnytyssairaala otettiin pois, sitten Warberg, eli keväthummon mielisairaala muutetti siihen tiloihin, ja hirveen kallista on kaikki kanttiinissa, ja minua moitittiin, kun uskaisin kertoa siitä, ni minä sain haukut päälläni.
"Hämon parkki paikka, ni siitä tehtii maksullinen, ja, eipä muuta, oi!"""No sirkkali salamin koski ähtäristä, hei, Etelä-Pohjanmaalta, minulle tulee näppyjä naamaan tästä, näistä, koko Suomen, mutta tietysti nyt Etelä-Pohjanmaa hyvinvointialueen, himmelista, ja onneks se joutuikin sitten arviointimenettelyyn, mikä tarkoittaa sitä, että kaikki poliitikot ovat epäonnistuneet Etelä-Pohjanmaalla päätöksenteossaan.
Esimerkkinä siitä on se, että, ähtärissä aluesairaalan mäki, tyhjättiit, jossa on kuntoutussairaala, vuodeosasto, sisätautiosaston, tuota, kirurkinen puoli, leikkaussali ja kaikki, sitten rakennetaan 35 kilometrin päähän alavuudelle, kaiken kaikkiaan liki 60 miljoonaa, monument, ja ähtäris on tilat valmiina.
Ko, olen ihan vanhusneuvoston jäsen, ja kyllä kentinen hoitaja sen talon, että on kyse jo tarappiassa siellä ollut töissä, mutta tämä, että valtion talous on tiukilla, niin tässä voitais säästää liki 60 miljoonaa sijoittamalla näihin, ja ne tilat ei oo homeessa, vaan ne on nyt ihan tyhjillä.
Tämä poliittinen päätäntä ei näköjään kuulu järjen käyttö, että tämä keskittäminen alkoi jo viime hallituskaudella, ja sillohan nää päätökset näistä tehtii pahoinvointialueesta.
Tästä pahoinvointialueen himmelistä haluaisin puhua, ja rahantuhlauksesta. Moi.
Mekkeli mies täällä. Taanoi, joku roffa julisti, että olkopää leikkauksesta on tarpeettomiani.
Voin sanoa kokemuksesta, että vuoden verran melkeeni hoidettiin kuntoutuksesta. Olkopäätä ei tullut kuntuani.
Se leikattiin, ja tuli kuntoon, se tehtii luohuoraatia, kun muuta, että semmoinen raffa puhuu ihan höpö höpöjä, ei muuta, ei.
Suomen Yleisradio täytti tällä viikolla, yhdeksäs päivä syyskuuta, sata vuotta. Onnea talolle.
Ennen Yleen liittyviä puheluita, muistutan, että kansaradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjan tai kello 21.
Jos merkkaa sydämen kuvasta, ja tilaa tohmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saa taina ensimmäisenä tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
No, Martipukalla pistää täältä, vanha pappa soittaa.
Hyvää pappa.
Minä ihmettelen tätä Yleisradin ohjelmaa televisiossa.
Joo.
Miksi niitten pitää herjätä ja haukkua Venäjä ja alastumia naisia C, C, P, lappujen kanssa?
Minä en ymmärrä tätä huiluutta Suomessa, mikä on vallannu notapiria lappua.
Sei, mikä tällainen televisio harmaa?
Siel on nyski ohjelma, sä, katuppa televisioa.
Nyt jalastumat naiset huutelee, hyppeelee lappu C, C, C, P, lappujen kanssa.
Kyllä, kyllä, kohta kulkaa, tulee turpiinko Putinin ämänäkkei Venäjälle.
Kailmaahan johtaa sairaat ihmiset, tämä rumpetti ja Putinin.
Tappaavat ihmisiä Ukraannassa eivät kävelitä yhtään mitään mistään, mitä politiikkaa ne on.
Ne ovat ihmisiä myös.
Minä ajattelee, Lauri, nii, että minunkin poika on Lauri.
Ja minä olen kasvattanut lapseni, on ollut ulkomailla töissä.
Minusta tämä on häpeää, nyt pitäis ohjelmaa neuvostan puuttua näihin televisioohjelmiin.
Tämä on ihan älytöntä.
Mikä sinä televisioohjelmassa erityisesti sinua häiritsee?
No, en sinä nykki ne osaukaiset televisio.
Alastumia naisia, tanssii tuossa.
Ni, tää alastumat naiset harmittaa.
Minua harmittaa kaikki tämä älyttömyys, mikä Suomeen on tullu.
Yleisradi on aivan perseistä.
Ei, ei jaksa ymmärtää tämmöstä, että miksi pitää olla loukata toisietä haukkua.
Samanlaisia apinoitahan on, nekiikö ne riisuu vaatteet?
Selvä, kiitoksia näistä näkemyksistä ja oikein hyvää sununtajatkoa.
Asiakunnissa, he.
Tupuu minua vähän tympäsee, ku tuolla televisiossa ne vain villauttelee.
Minä tarkoitan tuota kirjoitusta, kun uutisten jälkeen pannaa ei.
E, minä anakaa kerkiä lukijat, kun puoliväli.
Joo, hyvää, parivää.
Siitä on puhuttu, mutta eikös, eikös, mikä tollukka siellä niitä määrää niitä aikoja, että
siitä on kyllä puhuttu, ettei näytä se vattu kunnolla, eikä villauttelee sit, kun tuota.
Aminää luuleta harva siitä kerkiä lukijat, ennen kuin se sitä vuoliväliin, sitten se pitää tuota.
Loppuosa jää sitten arvaluvarraa.
Eli harmittaa, kun televisiossa vain villautellaan.
No nii, siellä vain villautellaan.
Näyttäis, jo oot kunnolla nii.
Sylvä, Tuive, on osannut läänään kansaradiossaan.
Joo, siitä on kato puhuttu kyllä.
Joo, jäädää seuraamaan tilannetta.
Tosiaankun pikkuisen pitempään pitää sitä kirjoitusta siinä, niin
olisi joku kuonompi älyminen kerkiä suu piestään.
Joo, heipää.
Hyvää päivää.
Kun nyt kuuntelin eilen tätä radiota, tätä sata vuotislaa, niin tuli semmoinen asia mieleen,
kun, muistan ajan, kun hodan jälkeen hävitetyn kodin tilalle nousi uusi koti,
ja sinne tilikeusettiin uusi radio.
Radiohan oli semmoinen, se oli viiskyt luvun alkupuolta, ja siinä, niin radio oli hirveän tärkeää.
Sieltä kuultiin uutiset, ja siellä tuli kaikki.
Mutta sitten, mikä on jäänyt mieleen, niin maan tai illan kuunnelmat.
Nihän oli ihan fantastisia, että koko perhe asettu kuuntelemaan, kuunneltiin,
ja ihan on mieleen jäänyt moniakin semmoisia ihania kuunelmia ja pätkiä niistä.
Se jäi niinko kuuntelin, kun ihmiset, mitä oli kaikkea jäänyt mieleen radioista,
ja pelkkariohjelmista, ihan aikaa nyt ei vielä televiselta ollut.
Et, mut radio oli tärkeää. Tietenkihän siellä tuli myöskin hauskaakin,
ja muistan aina kankkulan kaivon, jota naurettiin ihan katketakseen.
Siellä oli nämä speakerit ja neulosen mantotsummuut,
että niistä tulisi myös, olivat hauskoja hahmoja, ja hyvin tehtyä viihdettä,
että se täytyi sanoa hyvät näytelijät, ja siellä oli annoshäyristä ja hyviä radioääniä.
Radio on yhä tärkeää.
Että nyt ku tämmöstä kolkku tuulla syntyneenä, niin kanavani on radio suomi ja asia,
mutta myöskin sitten hyvää musikkiä.
Että kiitos, yles radio sata vuotta. No, hei.
Yleasialla jatketaankin vielä, seuraavassa puhelussa ollaan luonnossa.
Sitä ennen vielä yksi postikortti, aivan muusta aiheesta.
Kortin kuvassa on komeita omenoita, ja siinä lukee näin:
Hui veneet verolle.
Autoja verotetaan jo enemmän kuin tarve vaatii, ja ne ovat aivan välttämättömiä.
Jos on varaa ostaa vene, niin pitäisi olla vara maksaa myös verot.
Täällä tavoin luki postikortissa, jonka postimerkissä oli muuten radion sinfoniorkesteri.
Meille kansaradion voi lähteä kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen:
Kansanradio, PL, 79, 000, 24, yleisradio.
No joo, valtsu, tässä on taas piikkiöstä terve.
Nyt on lauantai viirespäivä, syyskuuta, ja telkkarist tulee joku luontoohjelma, jotai silkkiuikkuja, mitä siin on.
Ja ihme saakeli vinkutust ja kitinää ja musiikkii.
Miksin täytyi simmost olla? Miksei siin voi olla luonnon äänii, lintuja, lauluja, muuta tänäs?
Tätä on vissi joku muuki joskus ihmetellyt.
Ja kyl se tosiaan on kaikki luontoohjelmat, ja kaikis on vinkutust ja pimputust.
Minkä takia? Ei muuta, morjes.
Ja se, Anneli, haluaisin kiittää yleistä radioa, kun lähetät telkkarista tänne, yle, sataa, metalliklassikot,
meille, jotka eivät päässeet paikalle, tai ei ollut varra mennä, niin aivan mahtavaa ja hyvää on, nää, Yle, moi.
Ei saako lataa päivää?
Päivää, päivää.
Kyl soittelee, onnittelee, ylejä, ja yle, henkilökuntaa, yle, johtoa, ja kiitos, naisvuotista, vois kymmenistää.
Se on ollut ihan mukava, oot vuossairaan ollati kuuntelijää. Hyvä jatkoa sinne, ja kiitos, ku kuuntelitte.
Kiitos paljon.
Kiitos paljon, joo. No, hei vaan.
Hei, kansanrario, onneksi olkoon yleisrario, sata vuotta, toivotti, kansalainen.
Eki, rohanimelta, terveys.
Terve, terve.
Tämän päivä ohjelmassani, yks kaveri rutisee sitä, että turhanpäiväisiin ohjelmaa on merisää.
No joo, sitä on välillä kritisoitu.
Ilmeisesti tämä kaveri ei koskaan käynyt merillä tai seilanut, tai hän ees käsitä, mitä tarkoittaa kulkea merillä, koska ensinnäkin tuulen voimakkuus, venenpidan korkeus merkkaa sitä, että kulkahelppo tai vaikea, aluksen on esimerkiksi rantautua, satamaan.
Ja sen takia, tää sää on äärettävän tärkeä tietyyn väliä, koska tuuli muuttuu, venenpidan korkeus muuttuu, ja nää on niinku kulonarousia tietoja alusten kapteineille.
Eli, sinun mielestäsi, tämä satavuotias merisää puoltaa edelleen paikkaansa?
Ehdottomasti.
Kiitoksia paljon soitosta, ja hyvää sununtajatkoa.
Kiitos sinua, hei.
Tunnelmissa.Niitä ennen kerron vielä kansanradion puhelinnumeron.
Se on nolla, kahdeksan, nolla, nolla, yksi, viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä.
Ja puhelu on soittaelle maksuton.
Ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12:30 alkaen, tuossa numarsa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Noni, täällä Savo höpöttöjä tuossa. Radiossa oli semmoinen, et me tätä parasta rannikko saa asemata.
Ehtini, minä keksin tammosen legendan tässä, että paras. Niistä oli tieteni kotkar rankki.
Sielä mahottoman iso oli rankille tankki. Tankki asemajohtaja sinne hankki.
Rankki tankissa alvarissa, prosentteja keräs.
Sien pulupatuksen asema, pomoki, heräs.
Mäskiä sormellaan pinnasta hissukseen hipas, sitten keskaria kielellää lipas.
Tuumaset tisotessa täyttyy monikki hinkki, ja juuessa tulloo nenä väriksi pinkki.
Ja sliikoo, juo, juo, ja ryystää, männö, piä, sekasi.
Ei, ku se oli ni etäs, männö, sekasi, piä, ja ku selevämmät poistuu, yrjot lattialii, ja.
Ka se rätinki sekasi, haitannoko mittää.
Uuvet rätinki piä, se mulle ei.
Ei, muta ku on, ne aida menestää, moe.
Ei, aarola se täällä.
Yren, sata vuotta, aarotti yhdeksäs yhdeksettä, 1926.
Radioita suosittiin melkein kaikkiin koteihin hankittiin.
Mekiin kaksi sota-orpea, ilosta itkettiin.
Kun viisidoin, vanha radio lahjoitettiin.
Yre, radion olema upea kaari.
Kehitys suuremmoinen toteaa maari.
Ohjeumot aivan ilmeisesti viihdyttää.
Juontajat osaa hyvin niitä siivittää.
Radio on ku suuri karamellirasia.
Urheilu, luonto, musiikki, sät ja uutisia.
Näitä paljon lisää suosituin lienee, jossa kansa hyvää ohjelmaa vienee.
Lasse ja Lauri sen makeaksi juontaa.
Se minulta ja monilta kiitoksia tuottaa.
Yrpeänä voimme kaikki, yöjä, juhlia.
Ei sataan vuoteen syytä mitään tuhlia.
Kaikki, jotka puhuu isiämme kieltä, ovat varmaan kerrankin samaa vielä.
Näin minä sen ajattelin.
Ja kiitoksia hyvistä ohjelmista.
Ja hyvää ylin satavuotis juhlintaan osallistumista.
Heippa.
Marjametsään vielä ainakin tieimme vie.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa.
Kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
Hei taas kansanradio, tuossa uutisia kuuntelemini ja siinä sanottiin, että voiko työtön poimia marjoja, silloin kun on työttömyyskorvauksella, ettei sitä lueta nyt niin isoksi tienestiksi, että hän menettää sen ison työttömyyskorvauksen.
Kyllä aletaan hiuksia halkomaan, että kuinka nyt sitten, jos nyt menee tuolta ja poimii, kuulet muutaman ämpärillisen, se ei oka ihan helposti tehty se poimiminen, siinä täytyy olla hyvä selkä ja hyvä kuntoinen muutenkin, että kyl menee jo pilkun nussimiseks ja hiuksen halkomiseks, jo se ei työttön sais poimii marjoja ja sieniä, ja myydän niitä, niin paljon kun haluaa, ja ehtii poimia.
Kyl on jo maailma ihmeiseks menny, et jos työttömyyskorvaus sen vuaks evättää, jos nyt muutaman satasen saa marjoja poimimalla, ni kyllä on onnetonta touhua.
Kyl on jo presidentti Urho Kekkosen kanssa kirjakaveria, ja mullon Tamminiemestä on paljon kirjeita, että kaikki, mitä mä niiku puolustan, Aleksanteri Stuppia, hei hei.
Poika, soitaan tällä hetkellä tänne kansanradioon, ei mulle muuta.
Kiitos, ja moi.
Pelottaa nii petkeleesti, on luvassa ukkoskuuloja, se sanoi, se Tervonainen sanoi äsken, että ukkoskuuloja on luvassa, hei hei.